Mark: There's got to be something left.
Mark: Like there's got to be one thing left that we could do.
Tyler: I went through the list Mark. There's - it's...
Tyler: It's depleted, we got nothing left.
Mark: Wa- There's got to be something. Ethan, there's got to be ONE more challenge that we can do.
Ethan: Yeah there are challenges, there are definetly challenges that we can do, yeah.
Mark: Well, I mean, there's got to be something.
There's like, GOT to be something. We- we're creative people.
We can come up with this.
Ethan: Yeah.
Mark: We just have to think of an idea!
Ethan: Mhm!
Mark: Like....
*Looks for something to do*
Mark: The Accordion Challenge!
Ethan: YES!
- Mark plays accordion...PERFECTLY. -
Ethan: Dude, that's awesome!
Mark: Thanks, man!
Ethan: That's good, that's really good!!
Mark: Thank you!
- Still playing accordion with utter beauty and perfection -
Tyler: This isn't a challenge!
*fwoosh*
Mark: What do you mean?
We say it's a challenge...we CHALLENGE ourselves to play the accordion...
Whoever is best, wins! It's easy.
Ethan: Yeah, it's a great challenge.
It's one of the best.
Mark: Yeah, what's your problem with it?
Tyler: I mean, you can't just make a random like activity a challenge.
It's not a challenge. It's like "Watching TV Challenge!"
*They gaze upon the majestic TV*
Mark: Yes! Perfect! That's great!
More ideas like that! GO!
Ethan: Yeah! Uhh,
The Hand Sanitizer Challenge!
*Applies sanitizer*
Mark: Yes! Absolutely, yes!
These are great ideas! Write these down!
Uh, uh...the Googly Eye Challenge!
*Giant googly eyes....*
- cha ching-
♪ I AM THE ONE ♪
Tyler: No! You can't just combine an object or a word and add "Challenge" to it and make it a challenge!
That's not- that's not a challenge video!
Mark: Pfft. Alright, okay.
What do you think we've been doing?
You think the "Pumpkin Smashing Challenge" isn't just us having fun with a sledgehammer?
Ethan: You think the "Gingerbread Challenge" wasn't just an excuse for me to destroy some gingerbread houses?
Mark: You think the "Bottle Flip Challenge" wasn't just an excuse to flip Chica?
*weird-ass laugh*
Ethan: Yeah, dude, anything can be a challenge!
The Jumping Challenge!
- cha ching -
♪ I AM THE ONE ♪
Mark: Yeah! The Trumpet Challenge!
- plays trumpet flawlessly -
- cha ching -
♪ I AM THE ONE ♪
Tyler: Fine! Geez! The freaking light challenge!
*Wonders at the amazingness of light switches*
♪ I AM THE ONE ♪
- Group Sighs -
*Mark has been broken*
Mark: Okay, alright. I got it.
- cue "Roudabout" -
The "Try to Find an Ending to this Sketch Challenge"
(WOAH)
♪ Bah ba bah bah dum dum dum da dum da... ♪
*Pose*
- Epic outro music plays -